the partial shutdown of the federal
government lawmakers failed to reach a
deal to fund about one-quarter of the
federal government Friday because
President Trump is insisting on five
billion dollars in funding for his
border wall now nine federal departments
and dozens of agencies are closed and
more than 400,000 federal employees will
work without pay
Ouisa jiang is at the White House with
the latest we do good morning good
morning Anthony congressional leaders do
not plan to hold any more votes until
they have a deal they believe President
Trump will sign but now just three days
before Christmas it's still unclear how
long this stalemate will go on in a
statement the Republican National
Committee blamed Democrats for playing
politics but the DNC says President
Trump should be ashamed for targeting
American workers over his latest quote
temper tantrum we're going to have a
shutdown there's nothing we could do
about that because we need the Democrats
to give us their votes
president Trump blamed Democrats for the
partial government shutdown caused by an
impasse over funding for his border wall
we need a great barrier and if we don't
have it it's never going to work
before the shutdown vice president Mike
Pence along with acting White House
chief of staff make Mulvaney and senior
White House adviser Jared Kushner
huddled with lawmakers on Capitol Hill
but their efforts to find support for a
last-minute compromise were unsuccessful
would not be appropriate without a deal
federal agencies including Homeland
Security State Justice Department and
others ran out of funding at midnight
President Trump you will not get your
wall abandon your shutdown strategy
before Congress missed the deadline
President Trump said Republicans already
did their part is up to the Democrats so
it's really the Democrats shutdown
because we've done but less than two
weeks ago we said this during a
confrontation with Democratic leaders I
am proud to shut down the government for
border security Chuck so I will take the
mantle I will be the one to shut it down
I'm not gonna blame you for it
Senator Chuck Schumer said the president
can't read if accountability those are
president Trump's words and nothing he
says or does today can undo that
President Trump says the government is
prepared for a very long shutdown he's
supposed to already be at his mar-a-lago
resort by now to join First Lady Melania
and their son Baron for the Christmas
holiday but the White House says he will
remain in Washington at least for now
deena way Joe thank you for the latest
on that partial government shutdown